hallo wir sind heute an einer schule in
norwegen nämlich der ukraine tourist wir
drehen heute ein video über modell
werben
ihr seid jetzt verschiedene szenen in
allen sehen gibt es module werden
[Musik]
wir haben keine paprika kannst du
paprika kaufen
elise soll eine banane kaufen
wie fällt die treppe herunter das
gefällt ihr gar nicht er muss ihr helfen
[Musik]
erst müssen wir herrn gewaschen dann
müssen wir die paprika und tomaten
schneiden
das müssen wir den engen kurven
endlich können wir zusammen essen an
schneidet die weintrauben und malen
schneidet die bühne für den bruch dort
aber erst müssen wir das obst waschen
dieser schneidet die schokolade und leer
schneidet den apfel und und lisa mischen
alles zusammen
archivbild den fruchtzucker kleine
schüsse bevor wir essen müssen wir uns
die hände waschen anziehen ist mir
helfen den tisch zu decken er klar
jetzt können wir uns hinsetzen und zu
essen
der test misst das schmeckt komisch ich
mag dass es nicht die anderen aber schon